hello sir I'm gosh eunuch from I'm from
ban user so what does it take to be a
good scientist Sir sir is it the natural
talent of the boy or girl or it is a
nutshell the video nature in their early
childhood sir so if it is not sure then
how would you not sure the kids to
become the next scientists sir thank you
sir it is a difficult questions I can't
say that what is essential is a good fit
between the education and the initial
development of the of the boy of the
girl and what the difference between
animals and man is the duration of the
education facts the men you have the
education of a man the duration is 15
years 20 years and so we say that the
education is the most important thing to
to prepare the brain of our brand to to
be into the walk of science for example